The plant pregnancy project illustrates the
impact humans have on plants by encouraging
them to care for plants as lovingly as pets
or babies.
And tandem is a water-saving concept for public
men's rooms where a sink is combined with
a urinal.
Vsauce!
Kevin here.
This is MindBlow.
Uniqul allows a user to buy things with their
face.
The world's first facial recognition payment
system simply requires the customer to confirm
their purchase by clicking okay on a tablet.
The system recognizes your face and access
your information from its database and cuts
down transaction time to less than 5 seconds.
They're preparing to test the system in Helsinki
and in case you're wondering about differentiating
identical twins they're going to need to enter
a pin password.
The IH2 Azzurra Hand is the first robotic
hand on the market that is human-sized and
able to replicate real human hand functions
at human-like speeds.
Created by Italian-based company Prensillia
- it can grasp different items at different
weights with both power and precision grasps
as well as advanced digit manipulation and
sensing abilities.
And its uses range from prosthetics to humanoid
robotics and various research applications.
Akira Miyawaki is creating forests to reduce
tsunami damage.
The 1000 year Kibonooka project features dense
deep rooted trees planted in large mounds
created by using debris from previous tsunami
destruction and locating these along the shores
in Japan so that they can greatly reduce the
negative impact of future tsunamis by reducing
the energy potential of the wave.
This app lets you know in realtime which restaurants
have available seating.
The system collects data throughout the dining
experience from seating and ordering to paying
the bill by working with the restaurant's
point of sale system - giving real time exact
updates depending on the actual situations
happening inside the restaurant - giving users
in Japan the ability to choose a restaurant
based on seating availability.
Here's the design for the fold out solar charger
for the Volvo V60 Plug In Hybrid.
So yeah.
Boxed is furniture in a suitcase.
The adaptable furniture designed by Tyrone
Stoddart has the ability to be a coffee table,
a desk, two stools, and a lamp.
It then can all be broken down and put back
into its case to be carried off to a new location.
Fiberio is a touchscreen that senses fingerprints
freeing users from having to carry any other
type of identification.
The fiber optic plate the screen uses gives
it the ability to both display images and
sense fingerprints at the same time.
Applications for this could be in the workplace
where based on your fingerprints the system
would only allow you to access data that you
are given cleared for.
Bones of a new dinosaur were found in Utah
and they look kinda like a cow and a triceratops
had a baby.
The Medi robot created by the University of
Calgary was made to sooth children getting
vaccines.
The robot plays with the kids, high fives
them and teaches them relaxation techniques
for before during and after their shots.
And apparently he also does Tai Chi.
ERO is a concrete recycling robot that disassembles
concrete structures using water jets to crack
the surface of the concrete and then suck
up the debris.
The ERO makes the destruction of concrete
cleaner and more effective because previous
systems created huge dusty mounds of concrete
and metal to be sorted through and it also
saves a lot of water by recycling it back
through itself.
Finally here's female tungara frog attracted
to a potential mate and that is actually a
robotic version of her male counterpart.
I am going to leave you with a gymnastic robot
landing a quadruple backflip off of a bar
- and as always thanks for watching.